ouais mon pote un petit message pour te
dire que ce soir on fait une énorme teuf
à la maison et y aura juste tout le
monde emma youssef romain ça va être une
dinguerie t'es juste obligé de venir en
fait il me semble une semaine on est sur
ce projet et sur ce graphique en
camembert nous avons une grosse partie
en rouge une grosse partie en bleu et en
même temps et petite partie qui est
certes
quand on a comme ça une égalité d'une
toute petite partie ça ne marche jamais
on l'a déjà fait j'en viens donc vous
avez travaillé pendant une semaine
dessus il ya des résultats également
optimiser le côté rouge et vous le côté
bleu
parce qu'il faut aller vite moi j'ai
envie de résultats avant la fin de
semaine alors et tu me connais je suis
un énorme fan de star wars j'ai les dvd
après je le pamplemousse explose il ya
eu la révolution française non mais moi
je suis pas pour l'élevage en batterie
toi et c'est comme ça que je suis devenu
une liste trop moche moche moche il
semblait que
j'ai quand même levé notre
[Musique]
troll on attend les mecs ce soir je veux
que tous le monde dangereux du gros son
de la grosse du pas du du gros bide
quoi des fois des beats je raconte moi à
merde je l'envoyais est ce que tu
pourrais ramener des bières en fait
qu'elle a pu dans l'eau
oui
bonjour ouest pour moi merci super je
prendrai donc
si j'ai déjà fait plus on y
dresse mec c'est parce que tam était un
peu tendu chose je reste assis la
méditation ouais l'horaire de la soirée
écoute je pense que tu peux venir
franchement tu peux venir à
non le téléphone qui se fait ou
si lefebvre
[Musique]
ce stylo il est volatil passez
moi donc je viens pas de ya pas de
orange par exemple je disais il ya du du
rouge il n'y a pas de jaune tous à un
moment donné mais non
ouais mec j'ai pas le temps d'écrire des
messages par écrit moi je suis dans la
vie active en fait un projet très très
fat bon voila j'ai pas le temps
des douleurs qui en a gardé sa
ouais c'est bien c'est çà çà çà tu sais
mais bon camembert st
[Rires]
ouais j'ai fait ça pour te montrer que
je trouvais ça marrant après j'avoue
j'ai un peu exagéré de dire parce que le
travail n'était pas non plus
quoi tu utilises encore ton répondeur
toi mais que les messages sont tellement
j'ai la flemme d'écouté
[Musique]
au niveau des horaires en fait ça va
dépendre que chacun vient un peu comme
il veut tu vois
[Musique]
pendant que
je viens
à l'eau arrête de m'envoyer des messages
beaucoup reparlé en réunion au format
des messages écrits ces mille fois mieux
pour la discrétion mais c'est discret
donc là je vais raccrocher et retourner
travailler parce que moi contrairement à
toi j'ai un travail
d'horaires de pétanqueurs t'appelle
l'accueil de mon taf et tout laisse un
message au nom d'antoine lefèvre
antoine quoi
antoine lefèvre quoi moi
avec je suis vraiment désolé mais je
crois qu'il ya un petit quiproquo là je
pensais parler à mon pote antoine barioz
pas antoine lefèvre c'est gênant non
c'est connu au collège je crois
j'avoue c'est un peu gênant mais
pas du coup ce soir je viens quand même
à la soirée ou pas du coup
bakhit aime pas mais c'est vrai que la
base des invités donc non
bon bah vous amusez vous bien sans moi
du coup
châu hype
[Musique]
monsieur lefebvre la prochaine fois que
vous avez envie de contacter quelqu'un
en pleine réunion un petit sms suffira
et toi alors c'est plutôt message vocal
ou messages écrits diluant commentaire
non parce que je fais un sondage en fait
ce fut juste pour savoir nourrit pas de
mettre une cloche en l'air et de ta
bonne et au pouce non n'oubliez pas
d'activer
relâché plus anpihm merde tu fais ce que
tu veux